في النجاه كوزيره للداخليه على وشك النفاذ
بعد تراكم اخطائها في الاشهر السبعه
الماضيه وزياده الضغوط من قبل النواب في
جلسه طارئه تطالب بفتح تحقيق اخلاقي في
انتهاكاتها اخرها معلومات كشفت عن
مطالبتها بمعامله تفضيليه للتهرب من
محاسبه مروريه مخالفه فكشف من خلالها عمق
الخلاف بينها وبين رئيس الوزراء
المحرج على ما يبدو اذ ان النزاهه
والمحاسبه كانتا من شعارات حملته
التنافسيه على منصب رئاسه الوزراء العام
الماضي والاحزاب المعارضه لا تبدو مستعده
لتجنيبه احراجا او محاسبته على مكتب وعوده
فهم ساكت اعترفت وزيره داخليه سابقا من
خلقها القانون الوزري عند مشاركه معلومات
حساسه لذلك اسال اليوم كم عدد الفرص
المتاحه قبل تسريحها
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تواجه فيها
وزيره الداخليه تحديا خلال مسيرتها
السياسيه اضطرت للاستقاله في اكتوبر
الماضي خلال عهد رئيسه الوزراء السابقه
بسبب انتهاك تقني هذه المره انتهاك مروري
لم يكن في الحسبه كنت اسرع وانا اسفه انني
كنت اسرع قبلت النقاط ودفعت الغرامه
ولكنني لم اسعى في اي وقت من الاوقات الى
تجنب العقوبات
لكن خلف الانتهاكات التي ارتكبتها سياسات
جعلتها محطه جدلا بين النواب وتصريحات
وضعتها تحت الاضواء احيانا على حساب سوناك
فموقفها المتشدد تجاه طالبين اللجوء اشعل
احتجاجات حقوقيين وجدوا قسوه في سياسه
ترحيلها للاجئين الى رواندا كما ان خطابها
في مؤتمر لحزب المحافظين الاسبوع الماضي
زاد من التكهنات بانها تتهيا لخوض منافسه
على قياده حزب المحافظين قبيل الانتخابات
العامه عده عوامل دفعت سونات للنظر في فتح
تحقيق اخلاقي في ملابسات مخالفه يرى في
تجاهلها مخاطره بسمعه مسيرته السياسيه
وتفريطا في الوعود التي يعول على نتائجها
في الفوز بالانتخابات المقبله من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات